welcome back by the end of this lesson
you'll be prepared with a workflow
that'll make it easy for you to optimize
your images so that they take up as
little bandwidth as possible while still
looking great you'll be thinking about
image quality in size and with images on
the web it all comes down to size but
what does that actually mean here's a
question for you can you spot the
differences between these three images
to be honest I can't tell the difference
with my eye these three look the same to
me for this quiz check out the site in
the instructor notes then use dev tools
to work out the difference between the
three images are the differences caused
by compression level display resolution
the natural resolution or the file type
check all that apply